One piece of functionality that's still missing from our
Conference Central app is that so far there's no way
for users to register to attend a conference. Although
we see the register button in the UI, it doesn't
do any good to click it because we haven't
implemented the function that it calls. You're going to be
adding that feature next. The process of registering for a
conference involves several separate tasks,
including updating the users profile.
To know which conferences they have registered to
attend, as well as decreasing the number of
seats available for the conference. Also, what happens
if there's only one seat left for the conference
and several people try to register for it at the same time? Who gets it? How
do we handle those potential conflicts? We're going
to use transactions to ensure that all relevant entities
get updated, or none of them do, and to make
sure that only person can get the very last seat at
a conference. We're going to use a property called conferences
to attend to keep track of which conferences a user will
attend, and this property is going to be on the
profile entity. So in the profile class you'll need to add
some things. You'll add the conference keys to attend field. This
property contains the list of the keys for all the conferences
that the user has registered to attend, and
note that it's a list of strings. You're also
going to need. Most likely to fix the
import. You'll also need to define the get a
method for this property to return a copy
of the list, and rather than a regular get
a method. What you'll need instead is a
method that takes conference key and adds it to
the existing list. So we're going to call that, add
to conference key to attend, and this how you'll
define it. You'll add the new conference key to
the existing values. You'll also need to add a
method to remove a value from conference keys to
attend, in case the user decides to unregister from
a conference. So basically the unregister from conference method
simply removes the conference key from the existing values but
it needs to check first that the conference key
is already in the property and if not, throw
an invalid conference key exception. I mean, basically you
can't unregister from a conference that you haven't actually registered
for, and in the conference api class, you're going
to need to write the method. Register for conference. You
can start out by copying the skeletal code for
register for conference from the lesson four folder and copy
it into the conference API class. Here it is,
register for conference. We want this method to return true
or false to indicate whether the registration was successful
or not. The endpoint functions must return objects. They can't
return simple data type objects such as string or
long or Boolean. These are classical wrapped Boolean instead of
Boolean as a return type of the method. So
the file that contains a skeleton for register for conference
also contains a full-length commentation of the wrapped Boolean
class. So here's a wrapped Boolean class, it basically
has a couple of fields: results, and reason, and
the result is going to be the true or false, and
the reason is going to be the reason for the
result, and typically, you'll set the reason if the result
is false. We just have a constructor that takes
result and the reason. We have a constructor that just
takes a result and then we have getters for the result
and the reason. That same file also includes the definition for
the function get conference which returns a conference give a string
of its key. This method is used by the UI for
the app to get the details to show on the page
where you can register for a conference. You won't be using
it in your transaction, but you'll need to have it if
you want to use the UI to register for a conference,
and you're going to need to fix a couple of the imports. The named class comes
from javax.inject and the not found exception comes from
the server.spi.response package. So let's import
that, and you get conferences provided fully
implemented for you, you should be able to
understand the code that it implements. So
back to the code for register for conference.
We need to import a couple more exceptions,
and they're all in SPRM response. So you're going
to be implementing this code. So what you're
going to do is obviously check if the user
is null, and if it is, throw an
unauthorized exception. Exception, then you're going to start a transaction
and then you're going to write the code to get
the conference key, get the conference entity and if
there's no conference with the given conference ID, you're going to,
instead of just throwing an exception, you're going to create a
new wrapped Boolean. That's false and your going to need
to set the reason to explain why it's false, and your
going to get the user's profile. Your going to check
if the user already registered to attend this conference and if
they did, your going to need to create a new
rappedBoolean. Set it to false, and explain why. You're also going
to need to take account of whether is any seats left
and if not you're again going to have to create new WrappedBoolean
and explain that there is no seats left. Then if all
the conditions are met and if it's okay for the user to
register for the conference, go ahead and do the registration. So
you need to add the conference key to the user's conference keys
to tend property. You need to decrease the number of seats
available. You need to save the conference and the profile entities and
then you need to return a WrappedBoolean whose value
is true because this transaction requires a WrappedBoolean result
and then if there were reasons why it didn't
succeed, you're going to need to turn around and throw
the appropriate exceptions, and then finally return the result.
So one more thing to mention is that when
you do go ahead and book the seats, the
conference class already has a method book seats that just
decreases the number of seats available
in the conference. It's already implemented
in the conference class. So you can go ahead and look at that.
So all this code takes place inside of a transaction. So you're going to
need to know how to write the code for a transaction in Objectify.